en otros vídeos hemos hablado de los
derechos de propiedad pero en este vídeo
hablaremos con mayor detalle sobre cómo
se relacionan los derechos de propiedad
con los mercados
primero pensemos en lo que significa un
mercado para ustedes es probable que
hayan escuchado el término de mercado de
valores o seguro han entrado a un
supermercado para comprar provisiones
que tienen en común estas cosas una
definición informal de mercado podría
ser un mercado se forma cuando varios
participantes intercambian objetos de
valor
veamos si nuestra noción de mercado
coincide con lo que dice esta definición
en un mercado de valores tenemos a
muchas personas que intercambian
acciones lo que usualmente sucede es que
aquí tenemos diferentes valores que
pueden ser de una misma o de varias
acciones lo que típicamente ocurre es
que hay personas que les interesa vender
esta acción y hay otras personas que les
interesa comprar esa acción y cualquiera
de los compradores interesados en esta
acción que ofrezca una mayor cantidad de
dinero por ella la puede comprar y ese
dinero irá al vendedor de la acción
tiempo que la propiedad de la acción
pasa al comprador que pagó por ella
podemos ver que aquí ocurrió un
intercambio de cosas de valor en un
supermercado vemos pasillos llenos de
mercancías que estoy tratando de dibujar
aquí que podemos poner en nuestro
carrito de compras y ya que terminamos
vamos a la caja registradora y pagamos
por estas cosas así que de nuevo
nosotros elegimos las cosas que nos
interesan estas cosas tienen un precio
de esta manera el vendedor que en este
caso es el supermercado nos indica qué
es lo que quiere a cambio de esa
mercancía y cuando nosotros los ponemos
en el carrito y los llevamos a la caja
registradora indicamos que estamos de
acuerdo en pagar esos precios de nuevo
intercambiamos dinero por esas cosas de
valor el dinero tiene valor y la
mercancía que compramos también tiene
valor tenemos la idea de que los
mercados son la mejor manera de asignar
eficientemente recursos los diferentes
mercados funcionan de formas diferentes
aquí vemos que el mercado de valores
funciona de forma diferente a la del
supermercado también podemos tener
subastas en donde
oferta por diferentes objetos eso
también es una forma de mercado pero la
mecánica de su funcionamiento es
diferente al de los otros el factor
clave que se necesita para que los
mercados funcionen apropiadamente es que
debemos tener la noción de los derechos
de propiedad y como ya mencionamos en
vídeos anteriores los derechos de
propiedad se refieren a la idea de que
las cosas pueden ser de un único dueño y
qué significa ser dueño de algo es
posible que demos esto por hecho pero no
es una ley universal es algo que
nosotros suponemos culturalmente y está
tan embebido en nosotros que nos parece
natural que las cosas tengan dueño pero
existen tres características reales para
poder ser dueño de algo una es la idea
de que una entidad puede ser dueña de
algo exclusivamente por ejemplo
imaginemos que son dueños de cierto
terreno en el que quieren cultivar
esto significa que ustedes pueden
excluir a otras personas del uso de este
terreno y de cualquier cosa producida
por dicho terreno ustedes pueden usar el
terreno para correr dentro de él o para
tomar el sol o para cultivar cosas
ustedes tienen el derecho a los
beneficios de ese terreno
otra característica clave de los
derechos de propiedad es que esos
derechos deben hacerse cumplir qué
significa esto pues si alguien
desagradable quiere entrar en nuestra
propiedad en donde disfrutamos corretear
y tomar el sol le decimos a esta persona
que infringe nuestros derechos de
propiedad y podemos llamar a la policía
o algún tipo de agente de la ley para
que saque a esa persona de nuestro
terreno si es que nosotros tenemos el
derecho de propiedad de ese terreno y
esos derechos son exclusivos o digamos
que tenemos derecho de propiedad de
nuestros zapatos y alguien nos los
quiere robar nosotros podemos llamar a
la policía para decirles que se está
cometiendo un robo y la policía tiene
que hacer cumplir esos derechos de
propiedad devolvernos nuestros zapatos y
castigar de alguna forma al ladrón la
última característica clave es que para
que los mercados funcionen bien los
derechos de propiedad tienen que ser
transferibles recordemos que un mercado
trata de la transferencia de derechos de
propiedad en el mercado de valores una
persona transfiere sus derechos de
propiedad del dinero
al vendedor de la acción para que a su
vez le den los derechos de propiedad de
esa acción si esto no fuera transferible
entonces no tendría sentido tener un
mercado como lo conocemos hasta aquí
dejamos este tema por hoy estas son
cosas de la vida cotidiana que la
mayoría de nosotros damos por hecho
porque vivimos en una economía de
mercado y estamos acostumbrados a pensar
en que las cosas tienen dueño pero sin
duda hay otras formas de organizar una
sociedad que no tiene los términos de
mercados y no es tan claro quién obtiene
qué cosa incluso en la actualidad los
mercados en muchos sectores de varias
partes del mundo no operan de la mejor
forma porque algunas de las
características de los derechos de
propiedad no funcionan como deben quizá
en ciertos mercados sea difícil
transferir los derechos para ciertos
mercados quizá algunas personas se
apropian de cosas que no les
corresponden y el gobierno no es muy
bueno reforzando esos derechos de
propiedad o quizá es difícil evitar que
un tercero haga uso de algo de valor
cuyos derechos de propiedad pertenecen a
alguien más nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo